Hôm nay, 2 người từ thần Xin Nga 20, 2018,
tông tin từ công an tình lào kai, đơn vị đã hởi tổ phụ an.
Khởi tổ ba bị cân liên quan đến vụ việc nhóm bảo vệ đánh một người đi xem
máy trước sản bình Việt đã qua số một tình lào kai.
Các đời tự bị hởi tổ vụ, nguyễn tăng khai, Xin Nga 1 nghiên triên xam xóm mítam,
1 văn hoán, Xin Nga 1 nghiên triên xam xóm mươi, và hàng ngọt phang, Xin Nga 1 nghiên triên xam xóm mươi
cùng chú tại tình lào kai.
Thưa điểm xe ra vụ việc, cả ma đời tự tin đều đang làm việc tại công kí của phần dịch của đúng RGEP
i Xin Nga 1 nghiên tình lào kai.
Chứ đó, khoảng 18,5 người chiến thằng Xin Nga 2 nghiên phu xam 3 năm,
tài khu vực sản chính của bình Việt đã qua số một tình lào kai, anh hả mạnh giúp,
làm nghề xe ông, đang đỏ một bệnh yên trẻ thận nhân tạo của với người nhà về són trọc.
Giờ bầu thống, anh giống đả bị bà đứa tự tin, là bảo vệ bệnh Việt,
dung kể cầu xù đánh.
Hành vi của bà bảo vệ trên đá quay cảnh trở xó thông, làm gián đạn hoạt động khám chứ bệ,
anh hưởng bên ăning trực tự vào với bức xúc dưới lợp.
Căn cứ tài liệu, chứng cứ đá thương thật,
ngày 28 thằng Xin Nga 2 nghiên phu xam 3 năm,
các quan kể rất đều trà công an tình lào kai đã giác quy định hợi tổ hủ an.
Khở tổ bị càn đời với bà bảo vệ về hình vi về giới trực tự công cộp.
Hình cơ quan kể rất đều trà công an tình đang tích tục đều trà làm so hình vi của các đối tượng để sử li cho quy định của pháp lật.